petit stress de fin d'année pour les
élèves de l'union nationale du sport
scolaire dans le cadre de ce festival
d'activités physiques d'expression
derniers réglages pour kevin ses copains
et ses enseignants qui viennent de saint
louis pour cet événement qui clôturent
leur année c'est lac léman
en fait quand on est plusieurs il ya le
collège la chaloupe plus de dates deux
institutions donc il ya le crm de sainte
suzanne et nous les hommes de saint
louis et le collège de la chaloupe saint
leu
est un spectacle qu'on a travaillé sur
que de janvier à amener jusqu au tempo
festival
donc là on tourne un petit peu on dit
entre guillemets partout avec avec cette
pièce là tu es beaucoup de boulot
beaucoup de concentration
ça permet aussi de travailler aussi là
comment dire le travail en équipe et de
voir qu'il ya des personnes valides qui
peut danser avec des personnes à
mobilité réduite
et c'est vrai que ça participe à
l'acceptation des différences et ça pour
moi c'est quelque chose de très
important pour pour notre société et la
société nouvelle que voilà qui est en
élaboration avec avec tous ces jeunes
oui on voit vraiment une par expérience
que ça vraiment un effet positif sur eux
non seulement sur le plan moteur mais
aussi sur le plan de l'expression
corporelle au niveau de la communication
l'adaptation du comportement la
socialisante indiqué l'onu
oh
312 jeunes danseurs musiciens et
circassiens de toute l'île ont présenté
leurs créations
pendant plus de trois heures qu'est ce
qui a bien fait la musique ça nous
aidera à mieux danser encore la musique
à faire de l'export annoncé les ados à
aller à mon sens tu collage plateau
caillou et padalino notre amour pour lui
ici en même temps c'est des jeunes qui
étaient dans la rue qui prenaient des
risques et on leur a appris un peu à
s'échauffer
voilà canaliser leur énergie la danse
est une manière différente de la parole
de voir s'exprimer
c'est alors que caen dans ce n'est plus
nous mêmes ou des danseurs et le second
peu ce qu'on exprime est différent de ce
qu'on peut parler de la parole et je
trouve que c'est mieux parce qu'elle les
choses qui se disent pas par des mousses
intérieures c'est du bonheur
on a vu énormément de collégiens heureux
on a vu des collégiens épanouie on a vu
des collégiens qui viennent des eaux de
l'île collège la chaloupe collège de
cilaos collège de la petite île et on
pense fortement à ses élèves parce que
le conseil départemental aides en tout
cas les associations sportives des
collèges raid le comité régional
organisé chez ce genre de manifestation
et quand on peut le voir on n'a pas que
du sport qu'en pense unss on pense
forcément ce pan mais nous on pense
globalement épanouissement de l'élève
sait ce que veut la collectivité on a
ici des élèves qu'on va peut-être
retrouver dans nos théâtres
pourquoi pas et donc c'est l'occasion
pour ces gamins-là de découvrir de se
rencontrer et d'échanger sur leurs
pratiques
je
moi
lui et nasa s'est ainsi plaint de
diversité quel que soit son niveau toute
l'année 700 enseignants de paix s
accompagne ainsi ses jeunes au quotidien
surtout faire plaisir aux élèves et
surtout que cette première un premier
passage sur une scène parce que la
plupart de nos élèves ne sont jamais
venues danser dans un théâtre c'est déjà
une première expérience de la scène se
faire plaisir et montrer le travail qui
a été fait tout au long de l'année il ya
eu le championnat académique ou là il y
avait vraiment un podium
donc c'est une compétition et
aujourd'hui par contre c'est le festival
justement qui permet aux élèves qui
n'ont peut-être pas encore acquis
suffisamment d'expérience de montrer
leur savoir-faire sans savoir au bout un
esprit de compétition c'est vraiment
partager avec les autres ce qu'on a fait
tout au long de l'année et quand ce
festival se clôture et que ces 300
jeunes de tous les horizons se met à
danser sur scène des adolescents bien
dans leur peau alors la journée peut
être qualifié de succès